-My first guest
is a Grammy-nominated artist.
She stars in the movie
"Cinderella,"
which begins streaming on Amazon
Prime Video next Friday.
Here is Camila Cabello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my good-- Come on, now!
That's what I'm talking about!
-What up?
-I love you, pal.
Thank you for coming back
on the show.
I appreciate this.
-Oh, thanks for having me.
I've been having a ball
just watching you guys
do the Thank You Notes
and stuff.
-Oh, my gosh. Yes.
-I was LOL'ing.
-Sorry about that, yeah.
That took a while.
-And I loved it.
How are you, man?
Good to see you.
I mean, I've seen you --
I saw you like two weeks ago.
-I want you to come on the show
every night. Why not?
-I'll be part of The Roots.
-Yeah, please, come on.
We'd love to have you
as part of The Roots.
You're always welcome.
-Or I could just be like --
I could be your hype man.
Like, any time you say a joke,
I will be like, "Yeah. Right?"
-I will take that, by the way,
and use that,
even you just going,
"Yeah. Right?"
And they'll add it
through the whole show.
-Just like a button.
-Yeah, I want you --
I know we're
kind of best friends.
So I want to --
-For sure.
-Yeah. I want you to know --
I want you to clear
something up for me
because there's all sorts
of rumors flying around.
You did this TikTok video, okay?
And there you are.
-I do TikToks nowadays, yep.
-Yes, and it was
a giant TikTok thing.
But then look here. Looks like
there's a ring on that finger.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Ooh. Is this news?
And this is --
-No, guys.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. I cut you off.
-Wait. But that's it?
-Hand it over to you.
-You know what I'm going to ask?
-I know what you're gonna ask.
-Did Shawn Mendes
ask to you marry him?
-Um, he has not.
And I am not engaged.
I actually -- I just don't --
I still -- I swear to God,
I don't know what hand
the engagement ring goes on,
so sometimes I'll just, like,
put it on my ring finger.
And, I mean, I'd actually
like you to enlighten me.
Which hand is
the engagement hand?
'Cause I don't know.
My parents are married,
and they both lost their ring.
And so, literally, like,
my mom couldn't tell me either.
Like, she could
save me from this,
but she doesn't because
she doesn't know either.
-Yeah. It's the left.
It's the left hand. Right? Yeah.
-You don't even know! See?
Is this common knowledge?
-No, it's common knowledge.
But I'm trying to remember.
But when you do the wedding --
-Nah, you sound insecure
about this.
-Well, I almost ripped my finger
off with my wedding ring.
That's --
-So you don't wear yours either?
-No, I just -- I have
a tattoo on my lower back.
[ Laughter ]
-Hot.
-That says "Married." "Taken."
-Says her name.
-It says "Taken," yeah.
-I have a tattoo of Shawn
on my lower back, too.
Wait. We have the same tattoo.
Yeah. We have the same tattoo.
-It says -- It says, "Señor,"
and he has one of his
lower back that says "Señorita."
-Shawn was on our show.
Tell him we said hello.
He was nice enough to come
on our show early in quarantine.
I want to talk to you
about "Cinderella."
This is giant.
You are Cinderella.
-It's crazy.
-How does it feel?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, it's incredible.
You said it.
Like, it's just incredible.
I was in this kind of new
bad-ass version
of this kind of classic
fairy tale,
but it's told
in a totally different way.
And Cinderella is just, like,
a bad ass in this one.
And, you know, she's not waiting
for a prince to save her.
She's saving herself.
-Yeah.
-You know.
-Oh, I like that.
-And I feel like those
are the princess values.
Like, I feel like
the whole fairy-tale values
need to be rewritten for 2021,
and that is what Kay Cannon,
our fabulous director, did.
She just, like, rewrote it
for young people now.
So, yeah, it's very sick.
-Well, it's an awesome cast.
Idina Menzel, Pierce Brosnan,
Minnie Driver.
But my favorite,
besides you, of course,
is the Fairy Godmother --
is played by Billy Porter.
-Oh, yes.
-I loved it. It's so --
-Oh, my God, yeah.
And, like, in this version --
So there's, like,
the Fairy Godmother, and
he is the "Fabulous Godmutha."
[ Laughter ]
Which is how he says it.
-That's how he says it, yeah.
-And --
-How is he?
-Yeah, he'll be like,
"I'm your fabulous Godmutha."
-Yeah. How was he to work with?
-Oh, my God. He was incredible.
I mean, I was really nervous
when I first met him.
I was like, "Oh, my God."
He just has this, like,
huge soul, this huge presence,
this huge voice.
Everything about him
feels so, like, huge, you know.
And I just like --
He just immediately was
so disarming, and I was like,
"I'm, like, so nervous
to meet you.
Like, I'm such a huge fan."
And by the end of it,
he was like,
"Oh, I want to be
your Fab G in real life now.
Let's hang out."
-I love that.
-"You know, let's be friends."
And I feel like --
You know, my castmate Nick,
who was the Prince,
was, like, making fun of me
the whole time
because I feel like --
The thing that I was most
excited about in the film
besides the film itself
was just, like, making friends
and the friendships
and relationships
that I would get out of it.
And having a real Fab G,
having Billy Porter
as my real fabulous godmother --
-Not too shabby. Yeah.
-Pretty sick.
-That's pretty great, yeah.
-I love that you also -- Your
first acting role you chose --
You go, "Yeah,
I'm gonna be Cinderella."
Like, that's so cool.
It's perfect. I love it.
I think it's perfect casting,
and you're great in it.
Congrats, pal.
I want to show everyone a clip.
-Thanks so much, bro.
-Here is Camila Cabello
and Billy Porter
in "Cinderella."
Take a look at this.
-[ Gasps, screams, laughs ]
This is gorgeous!
-Yas, future Queen! Yas!
-What's that, Prince?
[ Gasps ] You'd like to dance?
Unh-unh-unh!
Get in line, Your Highness.
-Hold on.
[ Twinkling ]
-Where am I going?
[ Gasps ] Wow.
They're beautiful!
They're glass?
Any way you can make them
more comfortable?
-No.
-But you're magic.
-Women's shoes are as they are.
Even magic has its limits.
-Mnh. True.
Ow. Ow.
[ Laughter ]
-Glass slippers.
Congrats, buddy.
There's also great music in
this, as well. You're so good.